♪ BRIAN BRIAN ALL RIGHT.
GET THIS, GOVERNOR CUOMO STILL
PLAYING THE ROLE OF A HIS OR HER
IN HIS OWN MIND NOR MAN A YEAR
AFTER ORDERING SICK COVID
PATIENTS BACK INTO NURSING HOMES
CONTRIBUTING TO THE SECOND
HIGHEST DEATH TOLL IN THE NATION
THAT ACCORDING TO BRAND NEW
REPORT.
GET THIS, THIS AFTER HE RAN A
VICTORY LAB AFTER 06% OF NEW
YORK ADULTS RECEIVED A VACCINE
ADULTS LIFTING RESTRICTIONS THAN
ON THE ENTIRE STATE.
WATCH HOW HE CELEBRATED.
>> WHAT NEW YORK HAS DONE IS
EXTRAORDINARY.
WE WENT LITERALLY FROM WORST TO
FIRST.
WE'RE GOING TO LIGHT ALL THE
STATE ASSETS EMPIRE STATE
BUILDING IN BLUE AND GOLD AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FIREWORKS.
>> Brian: REALLY?
WE ARE OUT OF VENTILATORS WE
DON'T NEED VENTILATORS, RIGHT?
REMEMBER THE NURSING HOMES THAT
WASN'T MY IDEA AND THEN HE LIED
ABOUT THE NUMBERS?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE DEATH TOLL
52995 HE SAYS IT WASN'T HIS
FAULT.
HE GOT THE EUROPEAN VIRUS.
AND THE VACCINE HE SAID HE
DIDN'T WANT TO USE THE VACCINE
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP CAME UP
WITH IT.
OF THAT CERTAINLY CHANGED,
DIDN'T IT?
THERE EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
TELLING US ABOUT IT AND HOW SHE
FELT IS HOUSE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE CHAIR REPUBLICAN
ELISE STEFANIK.
CONGRESSWOMAN, OR I SAID
CHAIRWOMAN, WELCOME BACK, YOUR
REACTION TO HIS CELEBRATION?
>> MY REACTION IS ANDREW CUOMO
IS THE WORST GOVERNOR IN
AMERICA.
AND HE SAID ONE THING THAT'S
ACCURATE IS WHAT NEW YORK HAS
DONE IS EXTRAORDINARY.
WHAT IT IS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
FAILURE.
UNDER GENOMIC'S FAILED
LEADERSHIP, WE HAVE HAD THE
HIGHEST PER CAPITA RATES OF
DEATH.
WE HAVE LOST OVER 15,000
VULNERABLE SENIORS AND WE KNOW
THAT GOVERNOR CUOMO COMMITTED
FEDERAL CRIMES WHEN HE COVERED
UP THAT NUMBER THE TOLL OF COVID
AND WHAT HAPPENED IN OUR NURSING
HOMES, ON TOP OF THIS HE IS
FACING MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIONS
BOTH FROM THE NEW YORK STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE FEDERAL
LEVEL FOR THESE POTENTIAL CRIMES
IS HE ALSO FACING ASSUME
NUMEROUS CHARGES WHEN TO COMES
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT EMPLOYEES.
HE IS THE WORST GOVERNOR IN
AMERICA NO.
AMOUNT OF FIREWORKS PAID BY NEW
YORK TAXPAYERS IS GOING TO COVER
THAT UP.
THE NEW YORK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT HE HAS BEEN POLITICAL ABOUT
HOW HE HAS LED DURING COVID HE
HAS POCKETED $5 MILLION ON HIS
BOOK RUNNING A VICTORY LAP WHILE
NOT SERVING NEW YORKERS.
AND, AGAIN, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DEATH TOLL IT'S THE HIGHEST PER
CAPITA IN THE NATION.
>> Brian: HIS WARRING WITH THE
RIDICULOUS MAYOR DIDN'T HELP
THINGS AT ALL LACK OF
COORDINATION REALLY WAS DAMAGING
MOVE ON AND TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY
WHO HAS A JOB I CAN'T FIGURE
OUT.
CLIMATE CZAR JOHN KERRY.
WHAT IS YOUR QUESTION?
>> MY QUESTION IS WHAT IS JOHN
KERRY DOING?
IS HE DOING IT ON THE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS?
HE WAS APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO SERVE AS THE SPECIAL
ENVOY FOR CLIMATE ISSUES.
JOHN KERRY HAS BEEN FLYING
AROUND THE WORLD HAVING
CONVERSATIONS IN BACK CHANNELS
WITH THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
HAVING CONVERSATION WAS WITH THE
IRANIANS.
SHARING CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
PUTS ISRAEL IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION.
MOST RECENTLY HE WAS IN EGYPT.
HE HAS A POSITION THAT HAS A
SEAT ON THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL.
IT WAS NOT A SENATE CONFIRMED
POSITION SO THERE IS NO
OVERSIGHT THAT WAS DONE WHEN HE
WAS APPOINTED TO THIS
PRODUCTIONS WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS
HE ACTUALLY DOING?
IS IT FUNDED BY THE TAXPAYERS?
BECAUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TRANSPARENCY WE DO NOT
WANT JOHN KERRY SELLING OUT
AMERICA HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR ADVERSARIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
HE WANTS TO GET A CLIMATE CHANGE
CONFERENCE GOING UP AND RUNNING
BY NOVEMBER HE WANTS EVERYONE
READY HE WAS IN EGYPT.
I WOULD LOVE TO GET THOSE
ANSWERS.
LET'S MOVE ON AND TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE THAT MATTERS A
LOT.
THAT'S JOE BIDEN.
WE KNOW HE DOESN'T LIKE TO GO
INTO A LOT OF UNSCRIPTED
SITUATIONS.
WE ARE STARTING TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THINKS SCRIPT.
HE WAS SPOTTED AND TAKE A LOOK.
YOU ZOOM IN ON THE CARDS HE
HOLDS HE IS OVERSEAS AT THE G-7
NATO SUMMIT AND MEETS WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN IN GENEVA.
HIS CARDS REVEAL TALKING POINTS,
ANTI-TRUMP TALKING POINTS ON THE
DOJ.
DOES THIS SURPRISE YOU THAT I
THOUGHT THIS DOMESTIC POLICY
ISSUE YOU THINK HE WOULD HAVE
MAYBE SOME NOTES ON NATO, ITS
HISTORY AND WHERE IT'S GOING AND
RUSSIA AND VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
PEOPLE HE HAS KILLED?
NO, IT'S DONALD TRUMP.
>> YES, UNFORTUNATELY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN WE KNOW HE ALWAYS NEEDS
STAFF PREPARED TALKING POINTS
BUT WHAT IS REALLY DISAPPOINTING
ON THE INTERNATIONAL STAGE
PRESIDENTS TYPICALLY LEAVE
POLITICAL ISSUES AT THE WATER
WANTS EDGE.
WE TALK ABOUT UNIFIED AMERICAN
INTERESTS ABROAD.
NOT ATTACKING REPUBLICANS IN JOE
BIDEN'S CASE.
SO IT WAS VERY DISAPPOINTING TO
SEE THAT RATHER THAN, AGAIN,
TALKING ABOUT IMPORTANT ISSUES
LIKE BEING TOUGH ON RUSSIA
WHETHER IT'S OUR SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE TO COUNTER PUTIN'S RISE
IN THE REGION.
HE INSTEAD DECIDED TO BRING
TALKING POINTS TO ATTACK
REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY SHOULD
BE HEARING AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE AS ELECTED OFFICIALS WANT TO
SEE FROM OUR PRESIDENT.
>> Brian: CONGRESSWOMAN LASTLY.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" HAS NOTICED
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE OUTRAGED
AND ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER.
A CHRONIC PROBLEM THAT'S GETTING
WORSE.
WHAT STICKS OUT THAT THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" COVERED THIS STORY?
>> WELL, THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
WAS SO FRUSTRATED THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE UNIFIED IN OUR
MESSAGE OF OUTLINING THE MANY
CRISES THAT'S FACES AMERICA
TODAY BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES.
THE BORDER CRISIS, THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS, THE CRISIS OF CRIME AND
MORE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" ACTUALLY
WROTE A HIT PIECE, BUT WHAT WAS
AMAZING ABOUT THE HIT PIECE,
BRIAN, THEY TOOK THE TIME TO
OUTLINE ALL OF THESE CRISES THAT
ARE IMPACTING EVERY AMERICAN
FAMILY.
IT MEANS REPUBLICANS ARE
WINNING.
WE HAVE MOMENTUM ON OUR SIDE.
AND WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ISSUES
THAT MATTER TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND WE'RE HOLDING JOE
BIDEN AND NANCY PELOSI
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR FAILED
SOCIALIST POLICIES.
>> Brian: PERFECT SEGUE TO
TOSEEING TO NEXT SEGMENT.
THAT'S WHY YOU ARE ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE YOU CAN
BE TRUSTED WITH THAT I KNOW IT'S
YOUR FIRST CHILD AND GOT TO BE
EXCITING AND STILL GOING
100 MILES PER HOU